[Music]
5 25 on your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy how about going for a
fewer wrong way drivers on Tropicana
over I-15
that confusing diverging diamond
interchange was shut down for a night
last week for more tweaks including
changing the angle of green traffic
signal arrows from Straight Ahead to
Tilted to the left
speaking of veering or turning left
another tweak a new roadside sign on the
off ramp from North 15 to go West on
trop and that spokesman Justin Hopkins
says that ramp has seen some of the most
confusion so it's counterintuitive move
because you are normally when you take a
left you would cross traffic but in this
we want you to hug that left turn and if
you're going left stay in the left lane
all right Hopkins says there could still
be more overnight closures for whatever
additional tweaks may or may not be
needed we've got all of our diverging
diamond stories online including the
timing of the next complete freeway
closure of I-15 can you say drop a can
at 2.0
just go to our website click traffic and
then drive me crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation we are traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com